[MUSIC].
15,678 miles, 116 days,
35 states, one very dusty Honda Civic.
>> [LAUGH].
>> This is the road trip that changed my
life.
This road trip started with one goal.
For me to land a job, as a local newspaper
reporter.
But it lead me to much more.
It lead me to a new way of living.
This road trip way of living.
Is about having the guts to take that
first step.
It's about being open, and embracing the
unexpected.
And it's about taking the time to slow
down and reflect.
Get on the road.
Embrace the detours.
Slow down once in a while.
Let me tell you a little bit about life
before this road trip.
I left a good job in network television to
go to journalism school in New York City.
By 2003, I graduated with a dream of
becoming a newspaper reporter,
but newspaper jobs were scarce in New York
City, and
as hard as I tried, I had no idea how I
was gonna get hired.
I felt paralyzed.
Stuck in my shoebox sized studio apartment
in Greenwich Village,
glued to my tiny Ikea couch.
I was going nowhere.
How was I gonna get a job?
I had never been paid to write an article
before.
Had no published clips, no big New York
City newspapers is gonna hire me.
I spent days, let's be real,
weeks sitting on this couch in this New
York City apartment, the rising heat
of this New York City summer, and finally
I had, had enough of going nowhere.
It clicked.
What if, instead of reaching out to the
big editors at the big papers,
I reached out to editors in smaller towns.
Face to face.
At a small town, I could be, have my, my
own beat.
My own byline.
I could have my own voice.
And so I prepared to hit the road.
I took out a loan, I bought a car, boom.
I was committed.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Yeah, I bought a giant laminated map of
the U.S.,
I put little yellow dots of each town that
looked interesting.
I would go South.
And then West, I'll be on the road for 18
days, or so I thought.
I'll never forget that feeling of
exhilaration as I drove
across the George Washington bridge, my
new Honda Civic packed to the windows!
I was exhausted, from days of preparation.
But thrilled to finally be on the road.
Finally I was moving forward.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
In life we're taught to strategize, to be
deliberate.
Whether it's a job, a relationship, a new
home.
We really like to know what to expect.
But sometimes, the best decisions we can
make are based on no data at all.
Sometimes, you need to just push paralysis
aside.
And just get moving.
Just go somewhere, anywhere.
Sometimes you need to just get on the
road.
So that's what I did.
I followed that map, I went south,
Virginia, North Carolina,
South Carolina, Georgia.
I had my moot routine, I was gaining
momentum.
My process was locked.
Reach out to those editors, plan those
informational interviews,
show up in town, check into the Motel Six,
show up for
the interview, and be ready for the
inevitable question.
What are you doing here?
Why on earth would you leave New York City
and network television?
Do you really think this roadtrip is gonna
get you hired?
I would [SOUND] work my charm as best I
could,
smile, shake hands, write thank you notes.
I kept on moving.
This was my plan.
Dot after dot on the map.
Finally I got to Tennessee.
And the editor there suggested I reach out
to the sister paper in Little Rock.
But Little Rock wasn't on my original map.
I had already made plans to go to
Louisiana, Alabama,
I had to get up to Missouri, all within a
matter of days.
Little Rock would be an inconvenient
squeeze.
I'm not exactly sure why, but I ended up
adding Little Rock to my agenda.
A few days later I rolled into town, it
was late at night,
I checked into the first hotel I could
find.
The next day, I was pleasantly surprised
at the reception I got at
the Little Rock Newspaper.
The editor there was younger than most I
had met before.
He had reddish hair, a broad smile.
And when he showed me around this news
room, and
its lofty ceilings and sky lights, there
was an energy to the place.
The buzz of reporters working on
deadlines.
I sat down for an, an interview with that
editor.
He didn't ask the usual questions.
He didn't think this road trip was such a
crazy idea.
In fact he was impressed with it.
He was impressed with me.
He told me there were no available
positions at the time.
But he would reach out if anything opened
up.
And finally I felt like somebody
appreciated my efforts.
Finally I felt like I was making progress
and this detour, was paying off.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
Sometimes, the most amazing destinations
in life,
are not on our original maps.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
When was the last time you ditched your
Google calendar, and
made time for something spontaneous?
[BLANK_AUDIO].
When was the last time you put down your
iPhone long enough to have a conversation
with a stranger?
[BLANK_AUDIO].
These.
A, opportunities for unexpected
interactions are everywhere.
They happen all day.
Dozens if not hundreds of opportunities to
make these connections.
It's up to us to be open to these
opportunities,
meaningful ones, when they arrive.
That's how it is on this road trip way of
life.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
You get on the road, and you embrace the
detours.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
So after Little Rock, I kept moving west.
By then I was sporting.
Pretty serious left arm tan.
>> [LAUGH].
>> And often, I was driving for miles with
nothing but static on the radio.
I took this time to conduct my own sort of
interview.
I took my time to ask myself.
The tough questions.
I realized this road trip was giving me
the freedom to figure out what I
really wanted.
And I checked in to realize that I
actually did want to live in a small town,
because I wanted to have a big impact.
I wanted to make sure that I worked with
colleagues who actually appreciated.
My experience.
This is what I truly wanted, and after
many more miles,
many more interviews, I had found a new
focus.
In my final states, just the last few
miles, I got a call back.
From that editor, the one in LIttle Rock
who had been so impressed with me and
my road trip.
By then, there were no more questions in
my mind.
Yes, I said as he offered me a job as the
new Little Rock Prime reporter.
>> [LAUGH].
>> That sounds perfect.
Let's face it.
Even the most amazing road trips can be
tedious at times.
The roads can start to look the same.
The Motel 6's, I can assure you, are all
identical.
>> [LAUGH].
>> But there's value in this monotony.
Value in these long stretches.
Value in having nothing else to focus on
but what is right in front of you.
Some people find these moments in long
hikes, or meditation practice.
Some people find this time on a cross
country plane ride, without WiFi.
The gurus call it mindfulness.
Taking the time for the present moment and
your priorities.
And for me, the road is my mindful place.
My chance to slow down and reflect on what
truly makes me happy.
When it comes time for your next big,
life decision, remember this road trip way
of life.
Maybe you're feeling stuck, paralyzed you
dont know what to do next.
What if you push the risk assessments
aside?
And just got out there.
And just got moving.
Maybe you're already rolling full speed
ahead towards your final destination.
You know where you need to go, nothing
will stand in your way.
But if this is the case, ask yourself am I
on auto pilot?
Am I missing a chance for meaningful
detour?
[BLANK_AUDIO].
And every once in a while pause just long
enough to make
sure that where you're headed truly feels
right in your gut.
It's up to you to make this time for the
reflection.
For the mindfulness, for yourself.
Get on the road, embrace the detours, slow
down
once in a while.
>> [APPLAUSE].